good morning everyone and welcome to the
next video in the information security
space this video is going to deal with
computer security so what are we going
to cover in this video you're going to
start with what exactly is computer
security what are the types of attacks
that are possible on computers what is
it that we want to secure when we say we
want a computer to be secured properly
why do we get attacked in the first
place and how to secure a computer so
let's start with the first topic what is
computer security computer security is
the protection of computer systems and
information from harm theft and analyze
device so if you have a computer and
you've got some information on it the
objective of that entire exercise is
that you're going to try to protect the
information and the system from any harm
from external hackers or internal
hackers so in this scenario
dinah is trying to send information to
her manager but the information is
intercepted by the hacker and and the
hacker gets their hand on some sensitive
information that Dinah is trying to send
here in this case it's a password now
since the hacker has the password to
Dinah's laptop the hacker can then try
to get access and then steal data from
Dinah let's look at the type of attacks
on information security or computers the
first one is a denial of service or a
DOS attack in a DOS attack the attacker
normally tries to consume the bandwidth
or the resources that are available for
the server that is deploying the
application or that is allowing those
resources to be given out to the users
and once the hacker has restricted those
resources or has consumed those
resources there wouldn't be any
sufficient resources for end users or
legitimate users to consume thus denying
them the legitimate service and hence
being called a denial of service attack
here in this case there is a bot master
there are various BOTS and these BOTS
would then generate traffic or malware
and then try to attack the victims a bot
is nothing but a software that can be
installed on a victim's machine using
which the attacker can then remotely say
make commands to the bot and the bot
will then create that
fake to attack the victim so here in
this case the bot is nothing but that
software that has been installed in the
victims machine that allows the bot
master or the hacker in this case to
remotely send commands to the bot to do
appropriate actions the next attack we
are going to talk about is malware
malware is are nothing but malicious
software's that pose as legitimate
softwares but will have a virus trojan
or a worm embedded within it right it
could also be a key logger
a key logger is nothing but another
software that is created to catch all
the keystrokes that the user is making
create a copy of it and store it and
send it back to the hacker so whatever
the user is typing it will now be known
to the hacker it could be bank details
passwords any personal information that
the user might want to keep secret if
you are going to look at three different
demos yeah this demo is just to showcase
a couple of things we will going to look
at a key logger how a key logger works
this virtual machine here and I have
already downloaded a key logger and
installed it the idea of this demo is to
showcase how a key logger functions
right so you can see online on the
screen we are using a three key logger
or en dot soft on account here on this
side and you can download the free kirov
the right from here what I've done using
my demos is that I've always have a key
logger running in the background to
captured all the keystrokes that I've
been doing whenever I'm trying or doing
any demos so this key logger here can
actually be hidden in the taskbar but
for our demo purposes have kept it
visible when you click on it it will
open up and give you a basic screen
where you can start navigating about the
key logger they can see that on 8th
which is today it already shows some
keystrokes applications and some visited
websites as you can see already been
browsing using the browser over here and
which has been recorded by the key
logger in the background and just to
give you an example if I click on this
file you will see all the keystrokes
that I have been doing so far
and you can see I have gone to this open
up my Mozilla Firefox I have typed in a
clear search for key word of three key
logger then I have gone onto the website
how secure is my password dotnet in
which I may have tried out a few
passwords myself and then have gone and
copy pasted this
URL into the browser window and you can
see all of this has been recorded and
just to emphasize on that let's go on to
another website and let's say let's go
to facebook.com I am not actually going
to lock in I am just going to type in a
random username
so someone and simply run comm and a
password like ASD at the rate 1 2 3 4
and I'm going to try to log in obviously
the login is going to fail because this
account doesn't exist but we want to see
what happens in the background when the
key logger picks up the keystrokes that
we have typed so let's open up the key
logger again and go and see what is
there in the keystrokes and clipboard
and you can see over here that we typed
in facebook.com enter and then we did
not type in the username that's the
difference here we selected it from a
drop-down so a keystroke logger or key
logger has not been able to capture that
input a key logger in its essence his
only records something that has been
typed in by the user real time since we
did not type in the username it did not
record that username but we typed in the
password and he can see the password
over here ASD at the rate 1 2 3 4 and
this is how a key logger works it only
captures the keystrokes that have been
typed in real time so if we use this
exercise on our victims and they're just
using drop-down menus at that point in
time none of the data is going to be
recorded for that activity you would
need something which is known as spyware
which would capture screens which would
capture all of this information that is
going on now apart from just logging
keystrokes what this software also does
is it also has a list of used
application so you can see all the
applications that have booted up along
with the operating system and the ones
that have started up after the operating
system has booted it also has a list of
the visited websites you can see these
are the websites that we have been
visiting and they've been listed right
here the last one being Facebook log in
or sign up right so this can store
history for a really long time if I go
back in time and if I look at some of
the demos that I've been looking at so
on 14th of September these were the
keystrokes that I utilized when I was
doing some trainings over while I was
providing some demos on other topics so
a keystroke or a key logger will store
all that information and
kontrick recording it till you actually
delete that data or you can you can
reset the key logger you can also set up
the key logger to send the email to you
on a deal as a daily report to a
particular email address that you send
so as long as it detects the internet
connectivity this key logger will send
you an email to the email address that
you've specified with all the keystrokes
that it has locked now this is the free
version there's again a paid version for
it so you can go and visit this site and
see how this key logger functions if I
press on the X button over here it will
ask me if I want this to be hidden in
the system tray if I click on yes it
only using this shortcut will I be able
to invoke this screen so just for demo
purposes I do not want this to be hidden
so I'm going to click on no and you can
see that the key logger is still visible
over here so that was the first demo
that we are seen viruses as we all know
are destructive programs that once
executed would destroy data or harm the
hard disk or the partition tables worms
on the other hand would be software's
that would be more of a nuisance value
where they're going to replicate
themselves in such a way that they would
consume the resources of a computer does
crashing the computer and then requiring
a reboot a Trojan horse is another
software that will allow a backdoor
entry or a covert channel to back hacker
where the hacker in this case would then
be able to gain access to the victims
machine through the covert channel or
the backdoor without the knowledge and
the authorization of the user themselves
the next attack man-in-the-middle so if
you've been looking at the types of
attacks that we've been talking about
the denial of service attack was very
consuming the resources of the system in
such a way that they are no longer
available for legitimate users malware's
on the other hand would be softwares
that would either destroy data or give a
backdoor entry to the victims machines
for the hacker so a man-in-the-middle
attack is nothing but a network based
attack where the hacker is going to try
to intercept the communication or the
data flow between the victim and the
endpoint and thus when they grab these
informations they would then have
captured some data that different they
weren't supposed to get in the first
place so yeah in this example here
suppose you are in trouble
and you need money right now and you
call your friend
ask for money so here the person is
calling John telling John that they're
in trouble and they are asking for John
to give their credit card number over
the phone now this is a legitimate
transaction the friend is actually
calling John and asking for some help
however when John is providing that help
over the phone with the credit card
numbers maybe the CVV number and all of
that and then the OTP at the end of it
at the same time they could be hacker
doing a man-in-the-middle attack where
they could be eavesdropping on whatever
is being said or whatever data is being
transferred and once they captured this
confidential data they can then misuse
that data to their own gains the next
attack is phishing phishing is a very
common attack in today's world it is
where the attacker sane sends a bait
often in the form of an email with a
hyperlink in it to encourage people to
click on it thus getting redirected to a
malicious server that the hacker is
hosting and then end up giving out
confidential information
now obviously the requirement here is
that the email that is being sent out by
the attacker needs to look very
legitimate and needs to look genuine to
the victim for them to go ahead and
click on the link and provide that data
so here the example is where the email
has been received your customer your
account is going to expire today to keep
your account activity please click on
the link here and proceed with the
verification process now here the link
that we see activate comm would be an
hyperlink which is going to mask the
actual URL with the link is going to
redirect us right here the attack is on
the gullibility of the customer where
they would fear that the account would
be deactivated and to prevent that they
would trust this email click on the link
and then provide the information
thinking that they're just reactivating
the account but they're actually leaking
their own information to the attacker so
the first thing you have to understand
is banks or any organisation are no not
going to send you any emails with the
link in it asking you to reactivate or
anything like that
in fact banks proactively tell us that
they're not going to give call us and
ask for any information in fact they
would want us to call them on their
registered number or the helpline number
that they have declared on their web
site or on the cards that people
this the next time you want to talk
about is eavesdropping eavesdropping is
where you observe the traffic on your
system and the work that you're doing on
your system for example email traffic or
the website that you're visiting or what
you're downloading so eavesdropping
would essentially be the sniffing
attacks on networks where you're going
to sniff data packets and you're going
to try to observe the ongoings or the
data that is flowing between endpoints
between servers and you're just going to
try to observe it the next attack is
sequel injection or SQL addiction SQL
stands for structured query language
which is the language that is used by an
application to interact with the
database and the database to give that
information back to the application
right so any sequel injection attack is
where an attacker can inject malicious
input in that sequel query that is being
created by the application which if
executed by the database is going to
leak confidential data especially
they're going to leak data that these
users were not authorized to access in
the first place so the next attack would
be a password attack as the name
suggests this attack is used to crack or
get the password for users account or
when we say crack passwords this is
basically where somebody's trying to
brute force or they're trying to guess
the password and they're going to break
the password thus getting access to your
accounts there are five different ways
passwords can be cracked the first one
is a dictionary attack where we use
every password that is possible through
the dictionary now this is the use of an
actual dictionary and that's one of the
reasons when we try to create passwords
we are advised not to create passwords
based on dictionary words because these
are easily guessable and there are lists
already out there that contain all of
these words there's a tool that you can
utilize and that tool will then pass
through each and every word that is in
the dictionary file and then compare it
to a possible password if one of the
words matches the password has then be
compromised so if you are observing a
little bit higher security where we have
created a password that is not based on
a dictionary world then we want to look
at other attacks like brute force it is
a trial and error method so basically
what we do is we identify how the
passwords were created for example in
today's world the policies would be to
consume in
password any any of the alphabet
characters a through Z uppercase or
lowercase zero through nine and then
special characters and then we want to
randomize the usage of these characters
so that they are not easily guessable
but a brute-force attack at the same
time would then try every permutation
and combination there is possible in the
entire character set and then try to
figure out the password now this takes a
really long time and does take a lot of
compute and storage power and that's
where the botnet example comes in comes
back in the one that we saw earlier
which was used for DOS attack but
similarly if you have infected multiple
computers like this I can then
distribute this attack onto all those
computers and use the entire compute
power that is available to shorten the
time that is required to crack the
password now based this is 100%
successful given the time that it may
take so if the time that is going to
take is going to be a hundred years the
attack becomes unsuccessful because
during that period the password is most
likely to be changed but technology's
going to be changed and so on so forth
so if the password is easily guessable
this can be a very easy attack to
perform there a key lock up which is a
similar attack to what we have seen so
key logger has discussed earlier is
nothing but a software that once
installed on your machine would grab
each and every keystroke that the user
has made and store it in a file which
the hacker can later on access so
whatever you have been typing passwords
credit card information or anything else
all of those would be recorded and
stored in a file and that's one of the
best way a password can be compromised
then shoulder surfing this is a physical
attack rather than being a technical one
here you need to be physically present
when the user is typing in their
password and you actually look over
their shoulder to see what they are
typing and try to figure out what the
password is if they're quick typers it
is going to be a little bit more
difficult if there's no typos it's going
to be that much more easy and the last
one is called a rainbow table now
passwords where applications store them
are stored in hash format hash is
nothing but a one-way signature that is
created of the password file of the word
that is used for the password and it is
based on an algorithm so the input could
be a variable length 4
example a password could be seven to
fourteen characters but the output of a
hash value would be fixed based on the
algorithm that you're consuming so most
common algorithms in today's world that
we utilize are sha secure hashing
algorithms before that we used md5 or
message digests so all of these convert
the passwords from plaintext into a hash
value and store it into a database so if
you actually attack that database to
grab a password you're going to get the
hash value not the password in
clear-text and thus in that scenario
comes the rainbow table to the rescue or
rainbow table is nothing but a file that
will have a list of all possible
passwords along with the hash values in
the required format so if you remember
the dictionary attack that the exterior
attack was nothing but a list of words
based on the dictionary that was stored
in a file and then the software was just
trying each and every word against a
possible password here we do not have
the word but we have the hash value so
to reverse-engineer hash value what we
created is we created a rainbow table
whether it will be a list of other
possible passwords and their
corresponding hash values so we then
compare the hash value that we have
captured and then search for that hash
value in the file that we have created
the hash value that matches the
corresponding word to it is the password
in clear-text so these are the five
types of password attacks then moving on
to social engineering this is something
very common in today's world this is
basically where the prey is the human
itself and the reason social engineering
attacks are very successful is because
of the gullibility factor that a human
has for example human has something
called emotions that a machine wouldn't
you could plead with a human for a
password to be reset by gaining sympathy
or empathy but try doing that with a
machine those attacks are going to fail
social engineering attacks are not only
limited to those but we can talk about
phishing phishing is also a part of
social engineering attack where the
gullibility of the user to click on that
link is being exploited in this scenario
here this is clark is calling from the
ID security team that means that he is
impersonating probably and then telling
the victim that the system has been
compromised please share the password
with me the victim on the other hand
thinks that the person is trying to help
her probably doesn't verify that person
press that person and then provides the
password over the phone now here it is
fear that is being exploited because the
password being compromised would clearly
upset the end-user for loss of data or
for the computer revealing our
confidential information thus here the
she's trusting the IT to our security
team for the password to be reset and
given back to her now let's talk about
what to secure when we talk about
security we talk about the CIA triad CIA
not the agency but CIA stands for
confidentiality integrity and
availability and this is the basis of
which your security stands so any course
any training that you go through will
always talk about confidentiality
integrity availability and this is the
triangle or the triad that you're
talking about so when we talk about CIA
and we talk about confidentiality
confidential it is the aspect where we
want to keep the data secret based on
the value of the data to us for example
there would be data that is publicly
being displayed for example the data
that we publish on our website which
when a user goes on is clearly visible
over there but there would be some data
that the company needs to keep private
or within themselves so that the data
would have proprietary value to that
organization and that could be sold as a
business even within an organization
when you're talking about data there
would be classification levels there
would be data that would be made
available depending on the hierarchy and
the rules of people within that
organization so when we use those access
control lists and we try to keep data
available only to those authorized users
when they want it that's what
confidentiality is identifying and
classifying that data in such a way that
the data is available only to authorized
users as and when they want it now
integrity is the part where we want to
keep the data trustworthy even if
somebody is able to access it or allow
to access it they should not in an
unauthorized or an unintentional matter
manner be able to change that data
without it being audited now there would
be mistakes that a person commits at
some point in time where those mistakes
also need to be weeded out because
mistakes can basically alter the day
time such a way where it wouldn't it
would stop making sense so the integrity
part is where we are trusting the data
or we are ensuring that the
trustworthiness of the data is intact
so that consumers when they connect to
that data they can rest assure that the
data is valuable and is correct at its
point in time the availability part is
we're keeping the data confidential and
its integrity intact
we still need to ensure that the data is
available to all authorized users as and
when they need it so this is the three
aspects that you are going to use
confidentiality the first defense for
confidentiality is using proper access
control lists so we decide who's allowed
to access the data and who's not allowed
to access that data once we have created
the authorization we want integrity
verification mechanisms for example
hashing so we we have some data stored
we create hash values of that data and
we store them in a secret file we keep
on taking the hash value of those data's
to see the match so if the hash value
that we have taken now matches the hash
value that we had taken earlier the data
is still intact
it has not been modified but if the data
gets modified even by a single character
the entire hash value changes so if the
hash value of the current data does not
match the hash value of the of the data
that was taken before then the integrity
is no longer there now integrity
verification cannot be done on files
that keep on changing often normally we
will you see system critical files or
some very secret files that remain
static and do not change often only then
can we take hash values and then we can
compare them properly to see if they
have been modified or not the
availability part is clear creating
redundancy the infrastructure in such a
way that even if there is a small
failure we can absorb the failure we can
still move on and still that data can be
made available to the end-user motives
behind this attack
let's discuss motives behind these
attacks so the first motive of any
attacker
especially when you have discussed
denial of service or distributed denial
of service would be to disrupt business
continuity the business if discontinued
or if there's an interruption in the
continuity of the business would cause
great harm to the organization let's say
in lost profits lost businesses lost
revenues loss of goodwill service level
agreements not being adhered to which
would cause penalties to be paid to the
customers and the clients and so on so
forth apart from that information theft
and manipulating data hackers normally
would steal information from
organizations and then will try to
resell them on the black market or to
competitors so that they can make a
quick buck creating fear and chaos by
disrupting critical infrastructure this
is where terrorist hackers could attack
organizations or could attack
governments this crippling some of the
services that they provide to the nation
or to some particular areas thus
creating fear and panic amongst its
citizens and does humming the nation as
a whole financial loss to the target we
have all talked about banks getting
hacked money being stolen from their
individuals getting compromised by
phishing attacks and losing their life
savings
similarly organizations can also lose a
lot of money if they get hacked
especially with the new laws in the
market where they may have to pay
penalties not only do the customers but
two governments for failing to protect
particular data achieving States
military objectives countries keep on
spying on each other we have heard a lot
of news in the recent world where a
specific country like Russia was
supposedly involved in the u.s. election
and so on so forth so some of these
attacks could really happen in the world
in fact if you take into consideration
Iran and the nuclear strategy that that
created and what flames and Stuxnet
created as a havoc as far as Iran's
nuclear reactor was concerned demanding
ransom this is a very recent case in
2017 where Wallach I was released to the
world and it infected a lot of computers
costing the world around four billion
dollars in losses damaging reputation of
the target to a loss of goodwill you
wouldn't want to trust a business who
gets hacked right so I mean the thought
processes if you cannot secure yourself
how would we expect you to secure
critical data or sensitive data of your
customers and then propagating religious
or political beliefs we have organized
like Isis who have a lot of propaganda
online a lot of videos audios where they
keep on targeting people who are
susceptible to these kind of videos and
try to recruit them for their own for
their own causes so these are some of
the motives behind these attacks a
motive could be anything for example and
hacker could just be doing it for fun
maybe somebody is just trying to hone
their skills or learn new skills and
they just try to try it out against a
particular victim without the victim in
even being realizing it or the hacker
actually having nothing against that
victim so a motive could be anything and
everything that you can think of of
anything that would encourage a hacker
to attack a particular organization or
any organization at random now let's
talk about how to secure a computer now
there are multiple ways of securing
computers see these are some of the
basic ways we are not going into
advanced ways we are still not talking
about data centers you're looking at end
users you're looking at talking and
talking about securing computers so the
first and the foremost is a two-way
authentication mechanism
most of us use that on a regular basis
we have secured our Gmail and Facebook
accounts with two-way authentication
where we use usernames and passwords and
then an OTP or a one-time password is
texted to us or sent to a particular
email address which we then have to
input to then get access to the required
resources securing passwords we also
have been told quite a lot number of
times that passwords need to be secure
which means that they should not be easy
to guess they should not be based on
names they should not be something dear
to us shouldn't be a reverse of a mobile
number or a combination of date of birth
and the mobile number basically a
password should be randomized should be
of length of not less than 8 characters
26 characters is supported so it depends
how much you want to secure your
password with again there are so many
passwords to remember that's where we
actually start lacking in our password
creation skills maybe use a same
password for multiple accounts or then
create a password that we can remember
easily and then use those passwords but
in a sense a password
should be randomized should not be
created on anybody's name anybody's
likeliness should not be dictionary
based but should be combination of
uppercase and lowercase a through Z zero
through nine special characters and it
should be randomized the string not
should not be less than eight characters
can go up to 26 characters maximum
regular updates this is very important
when we use software's and we are
especially relying on third-party
software's for example operating systems
either we are using Linux Microsoft or
Mac there will be flaws and
vulnerabilities that would be identified
in any of the operating systems on a
regular basis and that is why when we
purchase a license we get free updates
for life of that operating system as
individuals it is important that we keep
on installing these updates these
updates may not only be functional in
nature but could also be security
updates for example Microsoft releases
security updates every second Tuesday of
every month these security updates are
collected together these basically are
patches that have been you know created
to patch the most critical
vulnerabilities the most common
validities that have been identified not
only by Microsoft but have been reported
to them by third-party organizations and
individuals as well and here I am just
saying Microsoft it could be anything
you could be using a third-party
application which you have downloaded
and installed you need to keep on
updating it it could be as simple as
management software's of maintenance
software's that you have installed on
your machines Microsoft Office if you
will any software once installed needs
to be maintained its patches to be
identified and installed on a regular
basis so that the most common known
vulnerabilities on those applications
would be plugged in thus reducing your
risk of getting hacked by an existing
vulnerability antiviruses in today's
world when we spend so much time on the
internet we interact with so many people
we send and receive emails with
attachments and we download a lot of
data off the internet now an antivirus
is there to help us to identify whether
any of these files that we are plotting
downloading receiving my attachments
could be malicious or could have a
trojan or a virus in each of the
antivirus job is to scan these files and
warn us if there is anything malicious
about that file then firewalls now what
is the difference between a ninety virus
and a firewall and antivirus scans for
files and malicious scripts or data
within those files firewall is a
software or a hardware that will allow
or disallow certain protocols or certain
connections from happening so firewall
is configured in such a way where you
allow certain protocols to work certain
ports to be open certain services to be
functional if a firewall is configured
to block a particular service any
incoming or outgoing connection as the
rule may be will be blocked by the
firewall
thus safeguarding the end user from that
kind of a connection phishing phishing
attacks are very common nowadays there
are a lot of anti-phishing toolbars
available on the Internet
I personally use net graft are these
anti-phishing toolbars basically look at
the sites that we visit on a regular
basis and then give us a risk rating of
whether the site is genuine or is a
probable fake site on a regular basis we
also receive emails from unknown sources
about lotteries that we have one or
Nigerian prince who has left a few
billion dollars and we receive SMS on
our mobile phones as well so we need to
first verify the authenticity of these
emails to understand whether these are
genuine emails of fake mails how to do
that we'll be looking at that in a
future video of how to unidentified
phishing mail and how to identify
whether the mail is genuine or not
cryptography encryption try to encrypt
as much data as possible but be aware
that with encryption you would be
consuming a little bit more compute
power maybe a little bit more network
bandwidth and a little bit more storage
so there has to be a fine balance of how
much encryption we want to use compared
to how much compute and how much
capacity that we have but in today's
world with the latest laptops having at
least 8gb RAM and I 5 processor being
common encryption is a very good option
once let's say an entire volume or a
hard disk has been encrypted even if
somebody tries to get access to it they
would not be able to understand the data
till they crack the encryption key to
decrypt that particular data when we are
transmitting data over the line we
always should be using HTTP
yes the S stands for SSL or TLS secure
socket layer or transport layer security
which ensures that data is encrypted
while it is being transmitted over the
Internet or the Internet and securing
your DNS servers DNS servers our domain
name servers which are basically indexes
that allow the mapping of a domain name
to an IP address for example when we
type in google.com in the address bar of
a browser the internet doesn't know what
google.com is there's a DNS server which
would host an index of all the domains
with their corresponding IP addresses
and it is these IP addresses that help
us identify devices over the Internet so
securing these DNS s is very important
for example if any if a hacker is able
to send a fake update to a DNS changing
the mapping of a particular domain with
a particular IP address and the hacker
then can host a malicious server give it
a particular IP address change the
mapping on the DNS server and thus have
unsuspecting users redirected to
malicious websites without them even
knowing what's going on
so securing DNS in today's world is very
much important let's go through some
slides two-factor authentication adds
layer of security to the authentication
process by making it harder for
attackers to gain access to a person's
device or online accounts as discussed
when we use online mechanisms or let's
say in this example we are making an
online payment and then we are on the
bank site we type in what are the
payment recipient is the amount and all
that data and when we click on pay we
need to authenticate that the payment
has been initiated by us and so the bank
sends a or a one-time password to us for
authenticating the transaction right
once we receive the pin or the OTP we
type it in the website on the bar on the
bank's website and then the transaction
is authenticated if the pin or the OTP
is incorrect the transaction gets
invalidated right there and then secure
passwords so as we have been saying
passwords need to be strong they need to
be created in a certain manner which can
be randomized so here we are prescribing
at least 15 characters now I understand
15 characters of passwords which are
unique to each and every account it
would be very
difficult to remember however it is the
necessity of the hour and this doesn't
mean that we create very complex
passwords and then write them down on a
piece of paper and keep that paper in
our wallet
that's defeating the purpose so we need
to train our minds and train ourselves
to create more effective passwords which
cannot be guessed or cannot easily be
cracked so at least 15 characters should
include capital letters should include
special characters like at the rate
ampersand hashes or percentile and
should include numbers so as we've
stated earlier a password should be a
randomized string of uppercase and
lowercase alphabet A through Z zero
through nine numbers and special
characters it should be randomized in
such a way that it should not be on a
dictionary word should not be a variant
of a particular word for example
normally we use the word PA SS w0 or wo
Rd as password and then to complicate a
little bit we use the variant P at the
rate SS w 0 RT these are still easily
hackable passwords because you are
commonly used by a lot of users in the
world so we have to be very careful and
we have to create those passwords which
are unique to us and are very difficult
to crack so for the second demo let's go
to this website how secure my password
is and this will get you a little bit of
an understanding of how long it would
take for a computer to crack the current
password that you have and I don't
suggest you actually type in your
passwords but just type in some random
words to understand the complexity of a
password and how more complex the
password more lengthy the password it
would be difficult for a brute-force
attack for a computer to conduct right
so here we assuming that you're doing a
brute-force attacks that means that we
are going to try each and every
combination of the character set to
crack a password and based on a regular
machine how much time is it going to
take for that machine to crack a
particular password when we say a
regular machine machine that an average
person can purchase in a laptop or a
desktop store right so if I just use the
word PA SS wo Rd you can see that it can
instantly be cracked because it's a very
well known password if you scroll down
it will also tell you that this is a
common password in the top five most
used passwords so people actually you
this word password as a password if I
use a variant let's say I do a P at the
rate s SW 0 Rd you will see that if even
if it's a variant it would take 19
minutes for the computer to crack this
password and if I just add a few numerix
so we have P at the rate s SW 0 Rd if I
add one two three four at the end you
can see that since the password is now
lengthy enough even if it is not complex
if even if it is not randomized since
the length of the password is quite big
now it will still take 200 years for a
regular computer to brute-force this
password even if I use random words if
the key length or the password length is
weak its small it's less it would still
not be sufficient enough for example I
am typing in Chandra characters B W P
you can see it's 400 nanoseconds 11
microseconds vwp a ft w P so even if I
am typing in random characters right now
all of them are low here and they're
easily guessable so it would still take
5 seconds for a group code brute-force
attack to work but as I keep on typing
in random characters and if as I
increase the length of the password you
can see the number of years that it
would take is increasing phenomenally it
is now 898 thousand years for us to
crack this password I don't even know
what I have typed so far but since the
key length is strong the password is now
efficient enough to withstand group
force attacks right so that's the reason
why not only randomness are we creating
a random password is important we have a
number of characters in a password it is
also very important so I would suggest
to have at least 12 characters to 18
characters in a password for it to be
effective enough against brute force and
dictionary based attacks regular updates
for all the software's is recommended in
fact if possible set it up for auto
updates if you're not comfortable with
that because it may require restarts and
it may consume a lot of bandwidth in the
background especially if you are doing
something that consumes bandwidth for
example you are a VoIP call and then
suddenly something triggers an automatic
update so we don't want those scenarios
to happen so you can still keep them on
a manual basis but remember to at least
check
updates once in a while maybe once or
twice a week would be recommended over a
period of time you would realize how
often the updates of an application are
being sent and then you can customize
and you can then vary your updates or
checking for updates as per your
feedback that you are getting so you get
updates because the older version was
hacked or was vulnerable some
vulnerabilities could be reported by
third-party users or some organizations
do a vulnerability assessment
penetration test themselves over a
period of time realize there are some
flaws and will create updates and send
it across to mitigate vulnerabilities
and divide assists in today's world are
a must you need to keep these anti
viruses and again an anti-virus would be
the perfect example of updates being
installed almost on a daily basis you
will find new signatures being created
for new viruses and worms and malware
that has been found on the internet so
it's just not thus that we install an
anti-virus and we forget about it you
have to install the antivirus you have
to keep it updated there would be
updates to the core antivirus that would
be released by the organization over a
period of time not only that your
signature databases would be updated
regularly almost daily for new newly
identified viruses worms Trojans etc so
installing an anti-virus and then
keeping it updated is a wanted task
firewalls as discussed earlier is a
system designed to prevent unauthorized
access to go from one private network
now what is authorized and unauthorized
is a little bit different as far as
firewalls are concerned firewalls will
not be looking at users and passwords
but they will be looking at connections
so you can configure a firewall based on
IP addresses port numbers MAC addresses
and maybe even Web Application Firewall
with certain scripts that are allowed or
disallowed will be discussing firewalls
in details later on in a particular
video right now they just focus on
having a good firewall installed and
having it properly configured and this
is where the technicality comes in so
you want to allow a particular channel
to to be utilized and you want to
disallow another particular channel from
being utilized you have to create the
specific rules in the firewall so at the
network level itself if any thread is
created the firewall will try to
mitigate it
once and for all fishing when you get an
email that looks suspicious you have all
you have to know religion to wit then do
the following never click on that link
given in the email for example you will
get a lot of hyperlinks maybe you get a
very genuine looking email from Facebook
saying there has been some unauthorized
activity on your account click here to
verify your account verify the
authenticity of that email do not click
on those links check the header of the
email see where the emails actually come
from or the best thing is right click on
that link click on copy link location
and paste that hyperlink in a notepad
you will get the underlying path to
where that link heads to verify that the
path is correct is actually owned by the
organization who the email is
representing if yes everything is fine
if not something is wrong do not give
any personal information or details if
asked you will see a lot of lottery
winning emails coming in and asking you
for personal information like date of
birth address phone numbers all of these
are very important to keep ourselves
secure on the internet as well or I
didn't this could be leaked out and
somebody could then hijack our identity
and create havoc for us so only give out
information to trusted people if you do
not trust the email try to verify the
authenticity if you are unable to verify
the authenticity reply back with the
generic questions asking for further
information about why you should reveal
that information if it's a genuine email
they would obviously respond with a
favorable answer if it is a unjam it is
not a genuine email you would not hit a
response do not open the attached file
so forgetting attachments from unknown
recipients or unknown senders and you're
not you're not able to trust that email
do not open the files or do not even try
to download those files and try to look
what those files are all about it could
so happen that there would be a virus
Trojan in that file and your computer
could get infected and then cryptography
or the encryption part that we talked
about encryption is best used to protect
our data the confidentiality part of it
so cryptography is associated with the
process of converting ordinary plaintext
into unintelligible text and vice-versa
so when we want to mask data
into being unreadable so if somebody
hijacks that data they would still not
make sense of it then use cryptography
encryption so on a regular basis your
banking transactions will always be
encrypted with the highest standards or
standards prescribed by PCI DSS computer
passwords they would not be encrypted
per se but cryptography would be used to
hash them and store a hash of the actual
password in the database rather than
storing the clear text and e-commerce
transactions would be interrupted at any
point in time apart from that if you
want to encrypt your own data or your
own transactions or any other
communications that you're making it's
up to you well deal with the encryption
little bit later as well but there are a
lot of options out there that will help
us encrypt data so let's move on to the
third demo we are going to look at
encryption are we going to look at
cryptography and this is one site which
allows us to look at text encryption and
decryption so how does this work if I
click on this link it will take me to an
application which allows you to encrypt
all the secret message that I can type
so I'm going to type in this is to
showcase encryption so for me to encrypt
this I'll have to provide it the
password let's say I'm going to use a SD
at the rate 1 2 3 4 and I am going to
utilize AES for encryption at once
encryption standards right the moment I
encrypted the data would look like this
in base64 and encrypted hex format right
if I provide the password correctly over
here only then will this be able to be
decrypted so if I think of the password
and I say decrypt you can see it says
bad data it automatically populated the
password itself where it says bad data
if I type in the password now and if I
click on decrypt it should be able to
reverse-engineer and give us the actual
message right there this is to showcase
encryption right that's what we had
typed so without the password if you try
to decrypt that or if it's a correct
incorrect password it's going to be
gibberish for the hacker if they if
they're able to intercept this message
the moment you have this password and
you can utilize this the message can be
decrypted and be seen in clear text so
those are the basic demos for this
particular topic as we go ahead we'll
start building on this demos and we'll
see how we can actually utilize these to
launch attacks on victims and how we can
safeguard ourselves from these kind of
attacks as
and that's it for this particular video
I hope this video was informative and I
thank you and appreciate your patience
of going to the entire video and I'll
see you in the next video thank you and
bye bye
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here